President Trump is set to visit the UK
next week in one of the top priorities
of Her Majesty's Government is
apparently keeping Trump away from Nigel
Faraj the leader of brexit according to
the Daily Telegraph which quotes an
unnamed government source British
officials have told our White House that
our president cannot meet with Faraj
during his visit the newspaper calls
that demand quote a redline for the
British government in other words an
absolute demand Downing Street denies
that that ban exists now shall Faraj
himself joins us tonight to clear this
up Nigel thank you for coming on thank
you a red wine our president banned from
meeting you can that be true oh yes
absolutely I mean don't forget the
establishment in Britain hate me they
see me as the man forced the brexit
referendum upon them helped get it
through they now have to implement
something they don't believe in and
worse still when Donald Trump becomes
the president you know and I was the
only British politician that said he was
the right thing
not just for America but for the Western
world Trump tweeted wouldn't Farrar's be
good as the British ambassador in
Washington and ever since that day
they've been paranoid about my
relationship with the president but you
know when you think about it who on
earth is some official in 10 Downing
Street to tell the US president who he
should that it shouldn't meet I'm sorry
to say but it paints my government out
of this visit in a very bad light it
certainly does do you know if the
president is abiding by this do you have
any plans to meet with him when after
country well look let's be honest about
this
relations between number 10 Downing
Street and the White House have not gone
as they ought to have done over the last
18 months two years I would not wish in
any way to cause any embarrassment for
the president coming over here so I
won't push it but Tucker if he wants to
see me for a cup of coffee
I'll go zoom I wonder if your government
is aware that it's on the wrong side of
history that's unfolding in Europe every
other country in Europe even Western
Europe
nationalism is reawaken as people
remember why borders are important
national identity is real etc etc the UK
government doesn't seem to be aware that
this is happening now it's very hard I
mean brexit was an earthquake in British
politics but the problem was the day
after the people's revolt the power was
handed straight back to those who
deposed the referendum and the result in
the first place so we're in a very
awkward place but you know I've spent
this week in Strasbourg with the parties
that are now governing Italy with the
party that is now governing Austria I've
met the Polish prime minister who says
look please Brussels don't treat us like
the Communists used to the revolution is
sweeping right through Europe and the
British at the moment are impervious to
it but you know what that situation
can't hold yeah I mean so how long will
you I mean your country is basically run
by a small group of very rich finance
people and immigrants the power is in
London right right how long can that
continue to be the Crown's I mean the
promise of brexit is that people outside
of one didn't have a voice in this - do
you think they will
well brexit proved that outside of big
business big banks and big politics
people can have their say and they can
win and right now we have I think I'm be
honest with you
the worst Prime Minister I've seen in my
lifetime who it's frustrating brexit if
we go on with this course of action in
this country then brexit will be not the
last earthquake but the first earthquake
more change will come in the end
people's views will be heard you know
Trump is part of this it is part of this
hunger is part of this Austria is part
of this do you know what Tucker freedom
is coming back to the Western world yeah
I mean if you're gonna pretend it's a
democracy you have to kind of pay
attention to the people who live in your
country - absolutely
Nigel Fresh thank you very much great to
see you thank you